Delphes
des lettres et des pierres,
des lettres gravées sur les
pierres,
florilège de noms des personnes du passé.
Pas de fonction commémorative
ici, ces noms/prénoms/pseudos ou simples
croix désignent les esclaves affranchis.
Des gravures, signes de liberté, liberté
des corps enrôlés de force, des milliers
d'humains libres de mouvement et de pensée…
Delphes, où l'on venait acheter sa liberté
et inscrire, sur les pierres du temple d’Apollon
sa signature, pour que jamais plus on ait
à se soumettre.
Des pierres à textes donc
mais aussi des prophéties, des paroles oraculaires
qui devaient orienter toute une vie de héros
de la mythologie, de rois ou de simples paysans.
Comprenez bien que Delphes, il y a des milliers d'années,
c'est le centre du monde.
L'omphalos, le « nombril » du monde, évoqué
par cette sculpture rhomboïdale, matérialise
ce point : le centre du monde, qui a reçu
toutes les offrandes possibles et imaginables,
d'une simple chèvre sacrifiée sur un autel
aux sculptures d'or, d'argent et d'ivoire.
Delphes, lieu de tous les rassemblements et
de tous les trésors.
Les Trésors grecs,
sortes de petits temples érigés par chaque
région ou cité prospère servent à remercier
les dieux.
Athènes, Siphnos, Naxos et tant
d'autres ont donné ce qu'elles possédaient
de plus cher dans ces lieux.
Pausanias, géographe et voyageur grec du
1er siècle de notre ère, aurait pu endosser
le rôle du vlogeur antique.
Dans son texte
Périégèse, il décrit tout ce qu'il voit
à mesure qu'il avance le long de la voix
sacrée du sanctuaire de Delphes
tous les trésors défilent sous nos yeux
même ceux qui ont disparus avec le temps
Une description d'époque
de ce lieu mythique et mystique sur laquelle
se fondent aujourd'hui les spécialistes pour
réaliser des restitutions 3D des édifices
disparus du sanctuaire
Si Pausanias a volé à notre secours, il
reste beaucoup d'énigmes à propos de ce
lieu et de son fonctionnement notamment au
sujet de la Pythie.
La Pythie est le nom porté par l'oracle de
Delphes, l’interprète du dieu.
Des générations d'historiens se sont succédées
sans qu'il
soit possible d'affirmer son identité et
son origine.
Dans ce cadre là, il n'y a que
le mythe qui puisse nous éclairer
Comme pour d’autres récits mythologiques
tout commence avec une créature monstrueuse
qui terrorise les habitants.
A Delphes ce n’est ni un Minotaure ni une Sphinge mais
un serpent dragon, appelé Python qui vit
dans une grotte à l’emplacement du site actuel.
Python, est attaqué par le dieu Apollon
et gravement blessé d'une flèche.
Il s'enfuit dans le sein de sa mère la Terre par la brèche
sacrée ouverte dans Delphes.
Apollon le poursuit dans la brèche sacrée et,
de ce combat,
des vapeurs mystiques appelées pythonisses
s'échappent.
Ces dernières inspirent l'oracle
qui de sa bouche prononce les mots d'Apollon
sortes de prophéties obscures appelée Loxias, capables de prédire l’avenir.
L’oracle de Delphes prédit à Œdipe qu’il
tuera son père et épousera sa mère, guérit
de sa stérilité Égée père de Thésée,
conseille Héraclès durant ses travaux, etc.
tant et si bien qu’il est presque impossible
d’échapper à l’oracle dans la mythologie.
Alors, une nouvelle fois et peut-être est-ce
la dernière,
demandons-nous ce que les archéologues
et spécialistes comprennent de ces récits
mythiques et en l'occurrence du rôle politique,
intellectuel et spirituel de la prêtresse
de Delphes.
L’une des premières recherche des équipes
d’archéologues a justement été de retrouver
cette brèche sacrée dans le sol d'où s'échappe
le pneuma (souffle, inspiration).
On a compris que le temple était bâti par dessus la brèche
et que la Pythie se plaçait sur un trépied à la verticale
pour en exhaler les vapeurs.
L’oracle, sans doute une jeune fille vierge
habitant Delphes, délivrait ses prophéties
une fois par mois. Avant la consultation,
moment de transe, elle faisait ses ablutions,
buvait de l'eau de la source Castalie et
mâchait du laurier.
Plus que les hypothétiques
vapeurs qui s’échappaient du sol et dont
il n’existe aucun indice sur le site, ce
sont sans doute les propriétés toxiques
du laurier quand il est ingéré à haute
dose, qui peuvent expliquer la transe
de la Pythie.
Elle répondait alors, dans un état
de conscience altérée, aux questions des
consultants, de manière brève. Des membres
du sanctuaire l’accompagnaient et avaient
la charge de reformuler ses conseils sous
forme de vers. Des assistants veillaient à
ce que le feu près d’elle ne s'éteigne
pas et sacrifiaient les offrandes des pèlerins
sur un autel dans le temple. Tout cela était
contrôlé par une sorte de « clergé » ou
confrérie religieuse.
Pourquoi Delphes ?
Pourquoi Delphes est-il
le centre du monde ?
Ce lieu primordial, où
se bousculent tous les habitants réels ou
mythiques de la Grèce antique, possède aussi
un mythe concernant sa localisation.
Ce flanc
de colline, n’a pas été choisi par hasard.
Revenons à notre bloc de calcaire sculpté
en forme d’ogive,
l’omphalos.
Selon la légende,
c’est sur ce point précis que
se seraient rencontrés deux aigles envoyés
par Zeus depuis les bords opposés du monde.
Si l’on suppose que les aigles divins volent
à la même vitesse, c’est imparable, c’est
bien le centre du monde.
L’omphalos serait ainsi la première pierre du sanctuaire,
elle
est décorée de bandelettes de laine qui
symbolisent le centre religieux et philosophique
du monde grec.
Pour les archéologues, cette explication
poétique n’est malheureusement pas suffisante.
Il faut comprendre les facilités offertes
par le terrain, sa géologie, son accessibilité.
Construit à flanc de colline, le site a été
choisi pour son emplacement sur un point haut
mais aussi et surtout pour la présence d’une
source, la Castalie, qui fait de ce lieu un
site favorable à l'établissement des populations
depuis l'âge du Bronze.
Pour cette raison, à partir du 8ème s. av. n. è.,
on venait
de tout le continent pour consulter l'oracle
des personnes privées, des représentants
de cités, des souverains étrangers tel Crésus
roi de Lydie et bien sûr les héros de la
mythologie.
Delphes tient ainsi un rôle
de premier ordre dans la colonisation grecque
de la Méditerranée puisqu'avant d'envoyer
des colons outre-mer, on consulte l'oracle.
Le nombre de monuments, de dons et d'inscriptions
que révèlent les fouilles archéologiques
à l'égard de la Pythie témoignent de sa
notoriété.
Cela explique pourquoi la volonté
de certains de s'approprier ce lieu
la cité de Crisa ou encore Philippe de Macédoine
et de dominer l'oracle a généré plusieurs conflits.
Delphes est une cité qui regorge
de trésors et les désirs d’appropriation
et de pillages sont également nombreux.
On estime qu’une bonne partie des donations ont été pillées.
Certaines pièces incroyables comme l'Aurige ou encore les statues chryséléphantines
faites d'or et d'ivoire
mais aussi le taureau d'argent
ont été conservées parce qu'elles avaient
été enterrées en 373 av. n. è. lors du
séisme qui provoqua l'écroulement du temple.
Finalement, en 381 ap. J.-C., le sanctuaire
est fermé par l'empereur Théodose.
Les fouilles archéologiques ont débuté
ici en 1840. Il a fallu 75 ans pour exhumer
une bonne partie des monuments du site.
Les œuvres sorties des fouilles sont devenues
immédiatement et universellement célèbres
l’Omphalos bien entendu mais aussi l'Aurige,
la Tholos et le Trésor des Athéniens
Mais ce qu’on ignore bien souvent, c’est que
pour découvrir les ruines de Delphes, il
a d'abord fallu déplacer le village ancien
alors établi sur le site antique.
Delphes
pour les grecs c'est aussi une histoire d'expropriation.
Aujourd'hui Delphi, ville moderne n'a plus
rien à voir avec le village du siècle dernier
tout en bois et terre crue recouverte de chaux.
Tout ce territoire est à présent un circuit
touristique bien rodé, aménagé de béton
et sa fonction agricole et son mode vie traditionnel
relégués au rang des curiosités bientôt
elles aussi archéologiques.
Parce que Delphes fut élevé au rang de centre
du monde,
on s'est permis d'exproprier toute une population rurale,
celle qui vit de ses productions
agricoles et artisanales.
Faire revivre les mythes en oubliant l’histoire d’un petit village
cela peut paraître injuste.
Cela n’a pas lieu systématiquement, à Thèbes
la ville moderne subsiste, nous privant sans
doute de vestiges magnifiques, à Athènes
aussi en partie.
Mais à Delphes, la tentation de savoir où se situait le centre légendairede la Terre
primait sur tout et les populations
sont devenues négligeables aux yeux des archéologues.
Oui, c’est aussi ça l’archéologie, donner
la priorité au passé de l’humanité sur
les besoins des vivants.
L'archéologie implique toujours une part de destruction,
ici quelques dizaines de maisons construites
par des mains de charpentiers déplacées
pour restituer les origines glorieuses de
la civilisation occidentale mais aussi pour comprendre
les origines des mythes.